لقد استعادت ممرضات وحدة العناية المركزة هؤلاء في جميع أنحاء
البلاد كيف بدأ الأمر مقابل
كيف يتم
نشر الصور قبل وبعد
التحولات التي تعرض لها
بشرتهم من 12 ساعة وهم يرتدون قناعًا
على أمل توضيح مدى صعوبة
عمل الممرضات
أثناء هذا الوباء وأن ذلك
ممرضة هناك
كاثرين تنضم إلي الآن ولذا
كاثرين سعيدة الشكر
وشكرا لك على كل ما تفعله
سعيد الشكر شكرا لك بروك
وأنا فقط أريد أن أكون شفافة للغاية مع
كل شخص يشاهدنا نحن في الواقع لا
نكشف عن اسمك الأخير تكريما
لرغباتك  لأنك قلت إنك بدأت بالفعل في
التعرض للمضايقة عبر الإنترنت لنشر تلك
الصورة مع أشخاص يتهمونك بالكذب
بشأن ما مررت به مع kovid
وهو أمر مأساوي
تمامًا وسنقوم فقط بتجاوز هذا
لأن هذا هو واقعنا
بالنسبة لك  لقد تم إعادة تغريدك لما يقرب من 90
ألف مرة استجابت الممرضات الأخريات كما
أظهرنا بصورهن قبل وبعد
كاثرين ماذا تفعل؟
لقد استجوبت رد الفعل على منشورك ، لقد اندهشت تمامًا ، لقد تأثرت ، لقد قمت بالتغريد على الفور بعد أن استيقظت من النوبة الليلية ، لذلك كنت متخلفًا عن السفر عندما نشرته ، دعني أعود إلى الوراء لذا فإن تغريدتك مع صورتك هي ممرضة جديدة تخرجت فيها للتو في مايو لتصبح ممرضة ، وفي مقابل ذلك لم تكن تتوقع بالضبط أن تكون ممرضة جديدة في وسط جائحة شديد التسييس كما كان الحال هذا العام بالنسبة لك ، نعم ، لقد كان الأمر سرياليًا ، أود أن أقول في كل مرة أقود فيها السيارة إلى العمل ، لدي على الأقل لحظة أعتقد أنني لا أستطيع فيها تصديق أن هذا يحدث بالفعل ، فأنا لا أصدق أنني ممرضة في خضم الجائحة ، لا أستطيع أن أصدق أنني ممرضة وسط جائحة لا يعترف به كثير من الناس ، لا أستطيع أن أصدق أنه حيث يُطلب الكثير من العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية بموارد قليلة جدًا طُلب منا الاهتمام بهذه الزيادة الهائلة في عدد المرضى أثناء العلاج  لم تزد rces حقًا
ولسنا قوة خارقة لا تقهر كما تعلمون
أننا لا نستطيع سوى فعل
الكثير وأريد أن أحاول
طرح سؤال آخر عليك ، وآمل أن يعمل wi-fi
ولا يقتلني روبرت ولكنني  أريد
فقط البقاء معها حتى تعرف أن
مسؤولي الصحة يحذرون من أنه بعد
عيد الشكر سنشهد زيادة
في زيادة عدد الجنود ، فأنت مستنفد بالفعل.
كيف تستعد أنت وزملاؤك من
الممرضات
فقط للتدفق المحتمل
للمرضى  في هذا الشتاء ،
أعتقد أننا في هذه المرحلة قد ذهبنا إلى الذهن ، لقد
مررنا ببعض الزيادات المفاجئة هنا في مسقط رأسي
ونتوقع تمامًا أن تكون الأسابيع القليلة القادمة
قاسية وفي هذه المرحلة بصراحة
نريد فقط تجاوزها  نظرًا
لأننا نعلم أنه سيكون أمرًا مروعًا ، فنحن نعلم
أن الناس سيموتون
ولا يوجد شيء آخر يمكننا القيام به في
هذه المرحلة بخلاف تجاوزه ،
ما الذي يبدو عليه اليوم السيئ بالنسبة لك
هو يوم سيئ عندما يموت الناس
وأنت  لا تستطيع فعل أي شيء
لإيقافه وواي  في معظم الأيام ،
نعلم في هذه المرحلة المسار السريري
الذي سيتخذه العديد من المرضى المرغوبين ،
ولكن نظرًا لعدم وجود
علاج نهائي حتى الآن ، فقد وصلنا إلى نقطة
استنفدنا فيها جميع
خياراتنا ونعلم أن هذا المريض
سيموت  ولا يمكننا فعل أي شيء حيال ذلك
، وفي الأيام السيئة حقًا التي
تحدث للعديد من المرضى على التوالي ،
تكون في الصفوف الأمامية التي
تراها تحدث ، لذا أخبرنا فقط كيف يبدو الأمر
عندما تكون في  المستشفى هذا الأسبوع
مقارنةً بالماضي ،
أعني أعتقد في كلمة واحدة أنه من
المحزن أن آخر مرة كنت في الخدمة ، اعتنيت
بخمسة
مرضى غطوا
العلاج وتعافى أحد هؤلاء المرضى وتمكن من
الخروج
من المستشفى  بعد حوالي أسبوع ،
أرسلت مريضين إلى المنزل في مأوى ،
ذهب أحدهما إلى دار لرعاية المسنين وسيكون
في الحجر الصحي الإلزامي لمدة 14 يومًا
هناك وهو لا أعرف ما إذا كان
سيعيش بعد الحجر الصحي
للمريض الآخر الذي خرجت منه  على
دار العجزة كان 4  كانت تبلغ من العمر سنة واحدة
وكانت خائفة من الموت
بمفردها والمريضان الآخران اللذان لديهما
كانا زوجين
في الثمانينيات من العمر وقد قبلت الزوجة في
اليوم السابق لدخول زوجها إلى المستشفى
وكانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي يذهبون فيها إلى المستشفى.
انفصلنا في 62 عامًا
، وتمكنا من وضعهم في
غرفة معًا
أم لا فقط حتى يتمكنوا من أن يكونوا معًا ،
كما تعلم عادةً ، يتم عزل هؤلاء المرضى الذين يعانون من
الطمع في
المستشفى وهم وحدهم أم ليس
لديهم زوار
وهم
خائفون وأنا آسف
لأنك تعلم أن فرص
عودة الزوجين في الثمانينيات من العمر
إلى المنزل
بعد قبولهما منخفضة
لأن الفرص أمام الناجين
ليست جيدة والزوجة أصبحت مريضة ومرضية
وتوفيت في المستشفى وكان على
زوجها أن يشاهدها وهي
تموت ولذا كان عليه أن يرى ذلك الخوف وهذا
الحزن
أممم وأنا لا أعتقد أنه لا أعتقد أنه
يمكنك وصف
ما يشعر به ذلك لنا كمقدمي الرعاية
لهم  يجب أن ترى هذا النوع من المعاناة
من p  المرضى وأنت
تعلم أنني كنت
في يوم واحد في المستشفى ، هذا
كل زملائي يختبرون هذا
في كل مستشفى
عبر مينيسوتا وأعتقد أنه من
الصعب حقًا فهم هذا
الوزن يا إلهي دكتور ، نحن آسفون جدًا  ومن
الواضح أننا جميعًا نستطيع أن نرى كيف ستلحق
بك الخسائر وأعتقد أن الشعور
بأن الناس يموتون بمفردهم
إنه أمر محزن للغاية وأنا أعلم أنه
عندما تتحدث إلى
الأشخاص القادمين وتسألهم من أين
حصلوا عليه
أو كيف حصلوا عليه أو إذا كانوا يعرفون كيف
حصلوا عليه ، فما
الذي يخبرونك به أنك تعرف مركز مقاطعة هينيبين الطبي
حيث أعمل هو
أننا موجودون في وسط مدينة
مينيابوليس ولذا فنحن مستشفى بشبكة
أمان تخدم هذا رائعًا حقًا  ومجموعة
متنوعة من المرضى ولكن هناك
الكثير من المرضى من
المجتمعات المهمشة والأشخاص الذين
لديهم موارد أقل
وإمكانية وصول أقل ، وبالتالي فإن هؤلاء ليسوا
مرضى يتم تغطيتهم لأنهم
يذهبون إلى الحانات والمطاعم
والأطراف التي تعرفها ، هؤلاء هم
الأشخاص الذين يحاولون البقاء بأمان ولكنهم
يتعرضون للخطر لأنهم
يتفاعلون مع شخص لديه رغبة في
ذلك ولذا
نرى الكثير من العاملين الأساسيين
الذين لا يستطيعون  البقاء في المنزل ،
نرى الكثير من العائلات التي
تعاني من انعدام الأمن السكني ، لذلك ليس لديهم منازل للذهاب إليها ، نرى مرضى دار رعاية المسنين الذين يعانون بالفعل
لأنه لا يُسمح لهم باستقبال زوار وقد
تم عزلهم منذ
شهور ولكن  بطريقة ما
يتعرضون للخطر ،
فنحن نرى عاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
تعلمون أننا نعتني بالزملاء الذين
نراهم في القاعات كل يوم والأشخاص الذين
نعمل معهم والذين يتعين علينا الآن رعاية
المرضى ونرى كاملًا  العائلات التي لا تستطيع
العزلة عن بعضها البعض
والتي أصبحت مريضة ، لقد اعتنيت
بامرأة
تعرفها بعد أكثر من شهر في وحدة العناية المركزة
كانت تتعافى
من كوفين وهذا يجب أن يكون فوزًا
ولكننا كنا نحاول الاتصال بأسرتها
كل يوم لمنحهم  تحديثًا ولم نتمكن من
الحصول على أي شخص
، ثم في أحد الأيام اكتشفنا أن
السبب هو وفاة زوجها من المعسكر
وتوفيت ابنتها بسبب
المعاناة أثناء وجودها في المستشفى ،
فكيف تخبر شخصًا ما
كيف  هل تخبر أحدا أن
عائلته قد ماتت